alors bonjour 6 à 10 ans que parlons
qu'alien il a au nom paulo
oh
[Applaudissements]
oui
et
je
m
[Applaudissements]
à
très beau c'est encore plus beau
qu'avant
devenu magnifique d'après le pdg lumière
est respectée tout j'ai peut-être oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et
[Musique]
c'est comment cette décoration du
palazzo lors des spéciales
on a fait comme si comme s'ils n'avaient
rien fait on a cédé père comme
constructive et nous lancer dans les
réseaux traditionnels ajouté rainer on
remarque la table et il avait bien trop
petit ou qu'il était saoul comme un
rideau à quoi et cela devient théâtre
est ici et comme un temps que je vis ici
mais ça fait dix ans de gens c'était
quoi ce lieu avant avance et un entrepôt
frigorifique et donc il est à l'époque
de là à l'époque de la guerre j'ai pas
que ce serait pour mettre un peu les
audiences étaient comme la jccd depuis
qui a arrangé ça fait tout était déplacé
là bas et les trains arrivés il y avait
d'ailleurs même les wagons qui
arrivaient directement ici dans la
mais bhl il y avait des rats et même
dans les couloirs ouais donc la
marchandise arrivée sur des petits wagon
directement ici c'est pour ça qu'elle
est les appartements sont en face pas
des appartements mais les lieux sont
assez fermé ça sert mais c'est pour ça
que quand ils gardaient l'immeuble de
l'extérieur ça fait comme un brouillard
épais a plusieurs à descendre les
principaux en plus parce que quand on
est chez toi et qu'on regarde pas la fed
on va voir je vais t'ouvrir c'est
étonnant ce convoi par la fenêtre parce
que le seul coup c'est une complètement
une autre cette ambiance très baroque
les goûts pour les chantiers ça qui est
beau c'est les buts marseillais maroc et
le personnel et tous les futurs un peu
des parts et des droits en train de
construire la nouvelle station de métro
qui s'appelle météo
c'est ça qui donne un côté un peu new
york j'aime bien parce que à ses côtés à
new york
mais ça c'est la dernière partie des
décors que j'ai fait cette espèce d'épée
téloche d'opéra là c'est drôle avec
l'exemple à 1 10 e et la 10 - c'est quoi
cette locomotive qui est ici alors à
l'hadopi et ça c'est une artiste qui est
mon voisin qui s'appelle jamais chef
jean-michel poids qui lui impute de son
travail d'artiste c'était mon travail
conceptuel et peinant cinq ans il a fait
toutes les démarches d'aller en pologne
pour récupérer une locomotive qui est
servi je cois pénale la guerre tu vas
pour
il va expliquer mais tu vas tout
s'achevant avec un b voilà très raide
c'est plus que rigola la locomotive
c'est toi là bas j'ai hâte de la voir si
cela venait de pologne c'est ça et c'est
une info motif qu'ils savaient
transporter les gens dans les camps que
ça c'est une autre motif de guerre et
elle était en pologne avec cerise un
truc le plus impressionnant c'est
l'odeur si vous n'êtes que en fait il ya
cette scénographie il voulait centrer en
premier le visiteur lui quand le lieu
est ouvert au grand public commence par
sentir l'odeur et la deuxième chose
c'est que l'endroit étant relativement
exigu par rapport à l'objet on est
impressionné par la dimension de l'objet
c'est à dire qu'on ne comprend que si on
avait cinquante mètres de recul on
serait beaucoup moins impressionnée tout
l'art que là on voit la locomotive comme
devait d'avoir les gens qu'on mettait
dans le train alors ce qui est troublant
aussi dense sur cet objet c'est que elle
a été construit en économie de guerre
c'est à dire qu'elle a été étudié pour
couper le moins cher possible être la
plus efficace possible avec la logique
de l'industrie allemande de l'époque et
ils ont créé cette espèce de monstre
c'est un monstre parce qu'en fait c'est
en quelques sortes un morceau d'une
montre voilà alors les les roues ont été
peintes
les bandeaux blancs des roues sont
peints avec de la peinture fluorescente
et c'était important pour moi parce que
c'est parti du de la réflexion sur
l'objet sur l'objet de l'histoire qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec un objet
d'histoire
comment faire de cet objet une oeuvre
d'art par une intervention éphémère
puisque la fluorescence disparaît qu'il
n'en reste pas de trace et par son
dépassement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux